if we knew the date of our Extinction
with 100% accuracy we could stop caring
about our environment and our
bodies we might focus on all the bad
habits that only bring us short-term
happiness our society could become more
violent more self Haring more inclined
to start
wars or we could team up and try to get
off this
rock we could start looking for other
places to move to beyond what our own
solar system has to offer
we could establish colonies with stable
human
populations then even in the event of
Earth getting wiped out by some cosmic
power humans would continue to
exist they could carry on until the
universe itself collapsed and stopped
existing but